thomas paul millet gérant de la sarl
maison pamiers exploitation agricole
située à orgeval notre ferme a été créée
par mes parents en 1978 qui sont arrivés
ici il y avait seulement
seulement des chaumes de blé ils ont
tous bâtis donc les bâtiments les serres
et ils sont implantés les vergers et
puis développer la culture du maraîchage
sur le plateau d élever notre
exploitation agricole fait 27 hectares
nous avons sur les 27 hectares des
légumes et du fruit donc en
arboriculture pommes poires prunes
fruits rouges ça ça correspondrait à 24
hectares de notre salut et le reste en
maraîchage avec un peu d'abri froid
comme celui dans lequel on est on a un
petit hectare d'abris froid voilà pour
faire l'hiver de la salades des radis de
la mâche et en saison on fait tous nos
produits d'été les tomates aubergines
poivrons
oui on a quand même des attentes au
niveau des élections on espère le
maintien de la dynamique avec les aides
à l'investissement qu'on peut avoir par
le département la région où l'europe
donc des aides sur l'investissement de
matériel ou des alternatives aux
produits phytosanitaires qui nous aident
à moderniser nos entreprises au
quotidien et puis on attend également
une réduction de charges au maximum sur
nos entreprises ce qui nous permettra de
garder la trésorerie sur nos entreprises
pour embaucher du personnel pour
continuer à moderniser l'entreprise
voilà et améliorer les conditions de
travail de nos collaborateurs